Unitas a largest airline to crack down
on the so-called emotional support
animals and said song the policy change
was prompted in part by passenger who
tried to board a United flight with a
large peacock on Sunday Delta announced
similar restrictions just last month CBS
News travel editor Peter Greenberg is at
United's hub at Newark Liberty
International Airport and that's where
that peacock was grounded Peter good
morning most people don't think of
peacocks as emotional support animals no
but they are in fact more and more
Airlines are reporting that the number
as well as the types of emotional
support animals is reaching crisis
proportions now we're not just talking
as you can imagine dogs and cats in fact
the interior cabins of some flights are
beginning to resemble Noah's Ark I'm not
kidding this woman is wrangling her
peacock into the airport United Airlines
says it warned the peacocks owner three
times that Dexter would not be allowed
to board the bird lives with an artist
in Brooklyn who claimed Dexter was her
emotional support animal in this 2016
interview she described how she found
him
but then this happened and I was like do
I have a pain in my neck
United Airlines already prohibits
non-household birds hedgehogs ferrets
spiders sugar gliders and other exotic
animals its new policy requires owners
to give 48 hours advance notice when
flying with a support animal provide a
letter from a mental health professional
and documents from a veterinarian
showing the animal is vaccinated and not
a threat to the public we've had
roosters and ducks and pigs and monkeys
Sarah Nelson is the president of the
association of flight attendants and
says she applauds the new policy changes
but what we really need is for the
Department of Transportation to act with
guidelines for the entire industry
United saw a 75% spike in comfort
animals from 43,000 in 2016 to 76,000
last year the critter sometimes relieved
themselves and damaged planes in June an
emotional support dog bit a delta
passenger Ken pigs fly in 2015 we show
how easy it was to get one on a flight
a Colorado Counseling Center provided
CBS this morning with a letter
prescribing the pig as the primary
treatment for a psychological disability
Tom Panik CEO of guiding eyes to the
blind says people are passing off their
untrained pets as service animals as a
person who is blind my access rights are
being infringed upon when somebody
passes off a fake service dog
now the new policies for United and
Delta kick in on March 1st and American
Airlines is expected to follow suit but
we should note that the new policies
only apply to emotional support animals
not the trained specially dedicated
animals that fly for and with people
with disabilities John Peter thanks yeah
people take people take their pets very
seriously we get it but you see a lot of
people taking advantage of that policy
so I think that's good that they're
trying to figure out a way to crack down
and make sure that the legit animals go